Starting tomorrow inshallah
salah
will be at 5:45
will be at 4:45
will be at 7:30.
Again this is starting tomorrow.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Tonight we want to read a narration of
the prophet sallall.aii
am which is in Muslim. This narration
comes to us by way of the great
companion Abdullahb.
It's regarding
the people who enter paradise and more
specifically
the very very last person to enter
paradise.
The last one.
This represents this person here that
we're going to read about
represents
the worstc case scenario
for the people of Allah.
Those who worship Allah,
those who
believe in Allah,
those whom Allah has mercy upon on the
day of judgment. The man we're going to
read about
tonight is the last of those people. So
you can only imagine
the
great majority of people
and the mercy that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala will show them on the day of
judgment.
He says,
[Silence]
he says, "I know the last man that will
leave the hellfire
and the last person from the people of
paradise that will enter. So this is a
person who
made a lot of mistakes. This is a person
whom Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
punished for a time, undisclosed
time. We don't know how long that is,
but long enough for him to be the very
last person to leave the hellfire and
the very last person to enter paradise.
He says,
Jenna,
it is a man that will come out of the
hellfire crawling on his hands and knees
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will then
say to him, "Go to paradise and enter.
Enter therein. go enter into paradise.
And so as he approaches the gate of
paradise,
he will start to feel and believe that
it is completely full, that there's no
room, no more room in paradise for him.
Why? the sounds that he will hear, the
glimpses that he will catch into
paradise, the smells, etc.
He will conceive of it to be completely
full. No more room for him.
And so he will return and say
and so he'll come back and he'll say,
"My Lord, I found paradise to be
completely full. There's no room for me
in there." And so Allah will then say to
him, "Go back. Go enter into paradise.
And so he will once again approach the
gates of paradise and he'll start to
have this feeling and conceive of it to
be too full for him. No more room for
little old him. And so he'll return and
he'll say, "My Lord, it's full. It's
completely full. There's no room for me
in there.
And so he'll tell him, "Go and enter
into paradise."
So on the third time, he'll come back.
He'll say, "My Lord, I found paradise to
be full. There's no room in there for
me. You told me to go in, but there's no
space for me." And he will say, "Go and
enter paradise
because for you is the best of the dunya
times 10."
So look at the best best most
pleasureful experience in this dunya
times 10.
That is what is for the least of the
people of paradise.
And so the man upon hearing this and
based on what he just saw when he tried
to enter he will say to Allah
he will say my lord are you making fun
of me and you are the king you don't
have to make fun of me on top of it are
you making fun of me
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala our
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
[Silence]
And so when the man says this in
disbelief, he'll say, "Are you making
fun of me and you are the king?"
And Iban Mas says, "I remember the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam
while he was narrating this to us and
telling us this. I remember him smiling
so wide that I could see his back
teeth."
And he then commented and said, "This
man is the least of the people of
paradise on the day of judgment.
This person will be given the best of
the dunya x times 10." And not just the
best of the dunya x times 10, but
without any of the perils of the dunya.
See, even if a person has the best that
the dunya has to offer now, there's
still death and illness and
forgetfulness and limits to a human
being's strength and a human being's
abilities, etc.
However, this person will be given 10
times the best of what the dunya has
without any of the perils of the dunya.
And that is the lowest person in
paradise on the day of judgment. That's
not the vast majority
of the people of paradise. The vast
majority of the people of paradise,
their place is unimaginable.
Unimaginable.
As the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
tells us that Allah said the narration
is in Muslim he said
Allah said, "I have prepared for my
righteous slaves,
a place the likes of which no eye has
ever seen, no ear has ever heard, and
has never
come across the imagination
or cross the mind or heart of any human
being.
This is what has been prepared for the
people of Amen. the people of belief for
you. This is prepared for you.
Paradise, eternity. It's right there. It
is there for you to take it. All you
have to do, all you have to do is reach
out and take it.
It is there for you. You have all the
technology that you need to arrive at
paradise.
You put the Quran in one hand. You put
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam's
sunnah in the other. You have a little
bit of sincerity in the heart and
a little quickness in your stride and
you can go and take paradise right
there. And you can make the day that you
die the best day of your entire
existence.
All subhanahu
and
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Another
[Silence]
It's his brother, right?
That's a fast touch.
Nice.
He's in Ohio.